whoever plays Jennifer Walters aka
she-hulk needs to have a commanding
presence in the courtroom as well as in
fight scenes and she also needs stellar
comedic timing here are a few actors who
would look great in green for Marvel's
Disney Plus she-hulk show Gina Carano
has had a long career in action roles
film fans probably knew Carano either as
the merciless henchwoman angel dust in
the first deadpool movie or as one of
Hobbes's secret agents in Fast & Furious
6
what makes Carano stand out as a
potential she-hulk is her real-world
experience in martial arts she started
out competing in muy Thai before
deciding to become an MMA fighter
winning all but one of her bouts her
martial arts background and muscular
physique would be great for she-hulk
superhero battles and her bravado would
work well during the dialogue heavy
scenes recently Carano has gained a
whole new fan base thanks to her role as
mercenary car at dune in the mandalorian
which also as luck would have it airs on
Disney Plus bringing her in to finally
play a superhero just makes sense Lena
Headey spent 8 years playing Cersei
Lannister one of the most compelling
antagonists in all of television Edie is
only five five in real life but you
could never tell on Game of Thrones the
actor is just that good at commanding
the room wouldn't it be great to see her
bring that Kamandi and energy to a super
strong super green lawyer as Cersei she
managed to balance her characters truly
human struggles with her ruthless climb
to power the challenge of balancing
lawyer jennifer and superhero Jennifer's
tricky but he can definitely pull it off
it certainly doesn't hurt that she has
previous experience with action scenes
in Terminator the Sarah Connor
Chronicles and the purge series plus it
would be delightful to see Cersei stare
down the biggest Bad's of the Marvel
Universe
Darcy Cardin is having a moment in
addition to playing Janet the helpful
celestial assistance on a good place
audiences have also recently seen her on
HBO's critically acclaimed Bill Hader
LED hit ferry while cheery personality
lists Janet was very funny in the first
season the rest of the series shows how
she slowly evolved into a more complex
and opinionated bean cartons versatility
shines in every version of Janet she
portrays the best Janet was the Janet
that was inside Janet she has a knack
for bringing genuinely sincere moments
into her comedic roles and not all
actors can pull that off a she-hulk show
would need that nuance to avoid getting
to see
- silly on top of her comedy background
garden did a little stunt work for the
good place and has said how much she
loved it as a series wraps up this is
the perfect time to cast her in
something more action-packed and a green
super-powered lawyer sounds just about
right outside of television adrianne
palicki might be remembered as the cold
conniving assassin miss Perkins and John
wick but her career is full of action
roles big and small her work in the
sci-fi comedy series the Orville mixes
action humour and science fiction and
with her 511 stature Palicki seems like
a natural fit for Shiho Palicki has
already been a Marvel hero as fan
favorite Bobby Morris on agents of
shield but there is precedent for actors
to play different superheroes even in
the same comic universe
Brendan Ralph joined the arrowverse as
the atom after his lead role in Superman
Returns while Chris Evans and Michael B
Jordan two different Johnny Storm actors
both went on to even bigger roles within
the MCU who says Palicki can't be
brought in to play a different superhero
Catherine Hans body of work runs the
gamut
there's maniacal Olivia Octavius a new
take on the classic Spiderman villain
Doc Ock in into the spider-verse
then there's the kind rabbi Raquel fine
in the TV show transparent and recently
she took on the title role on HBO's mrs.
Fletcher which explores the
vulnerability of being on your own after
your kids sleep for college Oh breathe
alright okay but I think maybe you
should listen to the campus i briefed
the roll proofs Han can embody the
hard-working side of Jennifer Walters
who genuinely cares about justice and
defending her clients however a role
that stands out above the others for the
span casting is the acerbic driven
political consultant Jennifer Barkley on
Parks and Rec Berkeley was only on the
show periodically but every appearance
was a treat
Todd portrayed Berkeley is completely
confident and pranked to a fault and she
can pull so much from that
scene-stealing role into the
sharp-tongued career-driven walters fans
have suggested that Aisha Tyler portray
Jennifer Walters four years at 6-foot
Tyler is certainly already the height to
play Shiho voicing secret agent lana
kane on the adult animated series Archer
Tyler has also proven she can play a
career-driven woman who also happens to
fight bad guys and blow things up Tyler
has been part of several talk-show casts
and knows how to handle a room on her
own much like Jennifer herself would
while her film and TV work is extensive
she hasn't had a chance to lead her own
show and this feels like the right bit
it doesn't hurt that Tyler is a
self-professed nerd either imagine how
hyped she'd be playing a superhero in
many ways Lord free pawns acting career
has always been tied to how tall she is
and her breakout role as Donna on that
70s show
one of the main running jokes was about
Donna towering over her boyfriend it
seems fitting for five-foot-ten
preponderant egde and a role like Chiho
where it wouldn't be treated like a joke
on top of that her smoky troll voice is
perfect for the dialogue and a show like
she-hulk
pre pot exhibits a cool confidence in
her various roles and seeing her walk
into a law office with all the swagger
of a super strong beautiful brilliant
lawyer would work really well for this
character since her time has fell on
Alex on oranges the new black is done it
would be fitting for pre pond to jump to
the other side of the legal system like
her co-star Lena Headey Gwendoline
Christie is at an interesting point in
her career her breakout role as Brienne
of Tarth on Game of Thrones won the
hearts of millions of viewers and yet
her short time as phasma in the new Star
Wars trilogy felt like wasted potential
now the game of Thrones is over it's
about time she takes her experience with
fight choreography and jumps into
another popular genre christy is a funny
charismatic person in real life but she
hasn't gotten to explore that in her
past roles Jennifer Walters would suit
her strengths to a tee and at six foot
three she's also the most physically
well-suited to play the character it's
easy to imagine what a blast Christy
would have in a big funny role like this
and she would totally rock a pantsuit
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]